hey what up guys my name is the chana
welcome back to my game engine series so
today we have a very exciting new
chapter to open up here and that is the
chapter of the entity component system I
don't even know honestly where to begin
over the last few episodes we've been
kind of cleaning up the engine I'll have
a link up there to the previous episode
in case you missed it and today we are
we're kind of going to be starting on
this new journey and this is going to be
the first I think major piece of it's
hard to hard to classify it I guess
maybe design pattern or like programming
pattern or something that we're going to
be covering as part of our game engine
series this is a structure that is going
to exist inside our game engine that is
going to be the basis for our entire
composition really of our scene so in
other words everything that is that is
our scene everything that is going to be
visible in the scene not just rendered
but also interactable I don't know if
that's a word something that we can
interact with all of that is going to
flow through this system this is a way
for us to organize our scene in this
video today we're going to be just and
this is gonna be this is gonna be quite
chilled but we're just going to be kind
of going to the drawing board taking a
look at what an entity component system
is how it works and why we would like to
go with something like this or ever may
be something that you might be used to I
don't want this to be like kind of you
know what is an entity component system
video although I am going to cover that
it's just gonna be more or less an
introduction to the ECS system in
general and I'll also be talking a
little bit about how that differs to
like a more straightforward kind of
approach to dealing with entities in in
a scene and why we specifically want to
go with an into component system because
I think that you know a lot of the point
of this series obviously is to share
exactly why I'm making certain decisions
and why I would like to do this as
opposed to something that might be kind
of easier because there's a lot of
there's a lot that there's it's it's
quite common that you might have a
temptation to go down an easier path and
usually that is the right path I'll say
but in a lot of situations it's
obviously better if you kind of design a
system slightly more complex because
either is going to perform better or
it's going to be better for a more
complex scene and some sometimes that's
a little bit difficult to do if you've
never dealt with like a large set of
data and if this is your first time
building a game engine so hopefully
these kind of discussions will help you
outfit that now we're gonna jump into
Photoshop in a minute and not that it
matters what program we're using and I'm
just going to you know draw some stuff
for you guys but the first thing I
wanted to say was that in terms of
implementation details I did mention
that we'll be using a library called ant
or entity depending on how you want to
pronounce it and in fact I'll fit over
here so I can show you guys so entity
which is kind of spelled like that is
essentially a MIT licensed I think
library available for use and just on
github it's about 17,000 lines of C++
code it's very much opt in meaning that
it's it's very fully featured that's why
it's so big but you don't have to use
everything and because it is mostly
templated you know it's you're really
only going to be compiling code and
using stuff that you need meaning that
because it's so complicated it's not
going to be slowing you down the reason
I've decided to go with something like
this
overriding our own entity component
system is because entity component
systems are they're they're very
performance critical and they're not
particularly easy to write now the
basics of an entity component system is
simple and I think that based on the
information I I'm gonna give you in this
video today I want you guys if you're
following along with this series in the
hopes of learning how to write a game
engine I really would encourage you to
actually try and build one of these for
yourselves because it's a really good
exercise and it's something we'll do on
this channel in the future as well but
I'm gonna do it right now but in the in
the future I'm going to revisit this and
we are going to write an energy
component system from scratch it's not
gonna be as good as entity or nth so
haven't decided the thing is I don't
want to call it entity because then you
won't know if I'm talking about MC or
ant so this is gonna be called ant from
now on just at least for this video
anyway it's not gonna be as good as this
because this is very like mature it's
well written I've
through a lot of I've looked through a
lot of the source code and it's quite it
takes a lot of things into consideration
and it is it's very performance friendly
and that's why we're gonna be using as
well I think minecraft Windows 10
edition uses it so it's got some big
names using it which is also good
because obviously they've built a larger
game than we have at the moment and
probably ever will so it's it's it's a
good piece of technology anyway we're
not going to be talking about
implementation details in this video
that was kind of my point here that
we'll be using and but it's you know
we're not going to use it today next
week next episode we're going to take a
look at integrating ant into hazel and
we'll probably set up our own kind of
layer on top of ant for how for how
Hazel's gonna interact with it because
ant is gonna be like our kind of
back-end implementation but the
interface that will provide which will
be like it's not gonna really you know
be performance intent like it's not
gonna cost any performance by having
like a thin wrapper over it or anything
like that but it's just gonna be like a
wrapper that I've essentially added in
it's already available in hazel dev and
it's just you know the way that I
basically structured the scene and also
made the API a little bit nicer for
Hazel's purposes because of course it
doesn't need the entirety of ant anyway
let's let's dive into this because I'm
I'm you know excited to kind of talk
about the entity component system okay
so the problem that we're trying to
solve here it's always good to kind of
take a step back and think about what
problem it is you're trying to solve
right so what are we trying why do we
need an entity component system so we're
getting to the point where we have a
scene right and a scene if essentially
like what is a scene we can define a
scene in many ways but essentially a
scene for us is almost like a container
that is going to hold different objects
and the thing is these objects we refer
to them as entities unity refers to them
as game objects Unreal Engine refers to
them as actors or pawns or a few
different things depending on what they
actually do these are essentially things
that exist inside this scene inside this
that do something now they can do many
different things for example we could
have a game object or an entity will be
calling them entities from here on out
that the game object entity same thing
we could have an entity in the scene
that is responsible for simply like
managing the UI display that tells you
what score you're on maybe you're making
a game like flappy bird and you want to
display the score here you could have an
entity that just runs since that just
run some code runs a script in the
background and does something handles
your meta game so in other words that's
an entity that you wouldn't even see
necessarily I mean the score would be
visible but let's just pretend that it's
not the skull is just pretended some
kind of meta game script that is an S
she'd exist in you're saying but it's
not rendered in any way because it's
just got a script attached to it you
could have your player write which has
to be rendered in some way maybe it's a
square on your screen and it has some
kind of behavior associated to it via
like some kind of script that's also
that would also be an entity you have
your world which might be made up of
various walls and various obstacles
those could all be separate entities
that you've positioned somewhere in your
world so we have this scene that is
essentially a container of a whole bunch
of different data that or that not only
has to exist somewhere and thus it
exists within this scene but also it has
to it has to interact it has to be aware
of what else is around it so in other
words we might have two entities two
little boxes here they not only need to
both be stored somewhere and thus that
kind of exists within the scene they
also need to be aware of each other and
they do that by existing in the scene
because whenever I move this and maybe
it needs to do some kind of physics
check to make sure that if it is this
box it collides and responds accordingly
then it can actually ask the scene hey
is are there any other entities around
me and if there are if there are and if
they have like colliders on them or
something like that then please tell me
so that I know whether or not I should
be creating some kind of physics
response right here it also might be you
know you might also have like some kind
of enemy in the world and then a player
and then the enemy has to be aware of
the player because if it gets like if
the player gets within a certain radius
you know
that we have like this radius around the
enemy here if the player gets within a
certain radius of the enemy the enemy
needs to chase the player again how how
does the enemy nor that there's a player
nearby because the enemy belongs to a
scene the player also is inside the
scene and via the scene the player sorry
the enemy can then query the scene and
figure out hey does anything else exist
in your scene in you that is around me
and if sorry then let me know if it's a
player or if it's like a different if
it's got a particular tag associated
with it and I'm going to you know I'm
gonna activate trace mode and based on
my behavioral script I'm going to do
something so for all of those reasons
you know it's important for us to have I
don't like that I zoomed in accidentally
but anyway it's important for us to have
a scene which acts as a container for
all of our different entities that we
want to have in that scene so that's
kind of step one right we need to have a
particular scene so once we have the
scene and this is relating all to the
problem that we're going to solve now
that we have some kind of sin we need to
be able to store these entities in an
effective way but also we need to be
able to provide these entities with
their required behaviors so as I
mentioned earlier an entity can do a
number of things an entity can be like a
3d model that gets rendered it could be
like a sprite - gets rendered it could
have just some code associated with it
that doesn't do anything it could be an
audio clip that gets played it could be
you know and we want to position it
somewhere in the world so that the audio
comes from that source it could be it
could have physics it could not have
physics it could be a light that we want
to you know shine it could be anything
so now we have the problem of so the
scene needs obviously it needs to be
able to store entities right because as
I mentioned it's a container so if it
stores entities how do we store them ok
well let's kind of take a look at this
right so what is an entity we haven't
even defined what an entity is but
because I mentioned that they have to be
stored in some way let's just say that
maybe we have like some kind of array of
entities and it doesn't really matter
what array this is right it could be
like a vector it could be a
it could be just a you know a
heap-allocated array it doesn't matter
because we're not talking about C++
implementation details we're talking
about more of a high level or a high
level approach I guess or I don't know a
high level overview of what that's
actually so we have this array of
entities right so if we have an array of
entities what happens if I have an
entity the differs from another entity
so entity a for example we'll call it e
EI I was gonna say I'm gonna call it a
let's call it MC 1 and XI 2 right I have
two different entities they're
completely different this one as I
mentioned you know that maybe this is
like a light or something like that and
maybe this is you know some kind of mesh
right which also happens to have an
audio source attached to it so if I have
a mesh that is also an audio source and
then I have this light thing here right
how are they both entities clearly
they're completely different so if I
actually dig a little bit into the
implementation how do I program this how
do I say that they're both still
entities right especially if you're kind
of in the object-oriented mindset and
you think about this in terms of like
okay well I have a class called entity
right how do I give this entity the
behavior of a light and treat it as a
light and give the scene the ability and
the renderer the ability to take that
entity and treat it as a light and pass
it into the shader and do everything
that it has to do with that light how do
I give it that behavior and then also
take the second entity which is the
second entity inside this dynamic array
or whatever how do I take that and say
that okay it's got a mesh which exists
in some kind of asset path and it also
is an audio source with these properties
and this is the audio file supposed to
play how do I compose all these entities
from different kind of features and I
can kind of see where if you know how it
what an easy s is you can see where I'm
getting with this but but how do we do
this and there are so many asses to this
I'm not even going to start to explain
all of them I'll explain a few of them
because you probably run across a few of
them but the first thing
wanted to mention was we have this whole
concept of an inheritance hierarchy now
what this means is that you have a base
class your class is called entity right
and from that entity you give that class
some kind of behavior so you might have
like and I'm not gonna write proper C++
code here but maybe you say that every
entity has to have a transform so I'll
have a mat for which is my kind of
transform sorry for the handwriting not
the best tablet and also I'm trying to
rush so we have a transform and then I
don't know maybe maybe we'll mandate
that every single entity has to have a
tag or a name or something like that a
right tag so I have a tag and I have a
transform that is the beginning of this
kind of inheritance hierarchy that's
what every single entity has now I want
to make a new entity that has that means
maybe a light so what do I do I make a
class that is my light entity I'll call
it light and this is going to be a
subclass of course of my entity and this
is falling apart maybe this was not the
best idea to try and hand write all this
but basically we have this light and
this will have extra behavior and in
fact let's just let's just switch to
this which I conveniently also have here
because I knew this would happen so in
summary you have an entity class right
and this entity class might have like
you know as I mentioned like a mat 4
which is like the transform it can have
you know at the tag and then we have a
light which is an entity
and then this might have extra stuff so
for example maybe we want to bec three
which is the you know yeah I guess FX 3
which is like the color maybe we want to
have like you know the intensity or you
know attenuation or whatever maybe we
want to have a type that describes like
an enum is it a point light is it a
directional line if it's a directional
light what's the direction you know
there's a lot of things I mean the
direction you could take from the
transform that anyway the point is this
is clearly something to require this or
its own data and then what about the
other thing that I mentioned it's a mesh
component so a mesh component oh sorry
mesh component it's a mesh what is this
it's if something is a mesh and also an
audio source okay so this is this is
already becoming a problem right and you
can see that because this is a mesh but
it's not just a match it's a mesh with
audio what so what I'm and what are your
mesh I'll make an audio mesh
I'll have entity in here you know sorry
it will be extend and see or it'll be a
subclass of entity I have maybe like an
audio clip or something like that and I
guess I'll need some kind of like mesh
or whatever okay but what happens if I
just want to mesh well I guess I'll have
to make a new class what happens if I
want to have have particular behaviors
associated with my entity so I have a
player for example well I guess I'll
have to make a player class which is a
bunch of things what if the player class
is an audio mesh because it has a mesh
and it also has an audio clip well
should I make it part of this this
becomes a huge problem this is already a
problem we have four entities we have
four entities could you imagine trying
to make a triple a game or like any game
really with this the thing is there are
trouble again there are triple games who
have done this but that's not the point
the point is this is not a very good way
to go and you can probably see why I
hope that at this point even with this
kind of crude simple example it was
enough to show you that this is a
problem the reason it's a problem and
we're not even talking about performance
does
matter about performance don't think
about performance at this stage at all
right in terms of what it's like to
maintain this card what it's like to
write this card what it's like to make
sense of the card right and extend it
this is a night map because it's very
clear that what we're trying to do is
we're trying to we're having to create a
completely new class inside our code
that contains certain behaviors right
and it's almost impossible to predict
exactly what behaviors are going to be
needed you certainly can't go in and as
an engine developer make every
combination of possible things because
you don't know what to expect
audio mesh is a good example you want to
audio clip in a mesh what if what if
this is also a lies what if this is the
player kind of and then maybe like or an
enemy
it plays an audio clip because it makes
a growling sound it obviously is
rendered to the 3d mesh but then we also
want it to shine like a flashlight well
should I add a directional light to it
it doesn't make sense it means that if I
have to if I want to make my own entity
I have to go into the code and I have to
make it completely completely in your
class and then what that means is that
we if we go back to what our scene was
and if and effectively I mean you know
let's just say it's a it's a it's a
vector of entities and these are our
entities then when I go through all of
these entities first of all I don't know
what to do with them right like how am I
supposed to do am I supposed to check to
see if it's a light or if it like what
do I do with this entities list well one
thing you could do is just have like
some kind of entity function here that
maybe you iterate through your entities
and then you have you know a function
that you can call such as you know on
update and this will kind of be with a
time step or whatever this will kind of
be your update function so now suddenly
you need to have this whole you know
virtual void on updates floor time step
you know with with particular behavior
associated with that you know with a
light like again I the light doesn't
make sense to me because how the light
is something that the renderer should be
taking care of but like I am I supposed
to write a function here that deals with
lives again what happens if
one slide it becomes a huge issue I'm
not even going to continue this because
it's actually kind of confusing me it's
very difficult to try and write a large
a large piece of modular code if you're
thinking in that kind of inheritance
hierarchy thing and the thing is that's
that's a very simple approach to writing
a game and and I don't doubt that for
small games that's probably fine you
don't need to go with a full ECS for
something like that
but a TCS makes this stuff a lot easier
and the reason it makes things a lot
easier is because it introduces the
concept of components and thus
composition what that means is that
everything that I just mentioned there I
think I deleted all of it which is
probably a bad move luckily control-z
lists everything that we have here what
what is happening here is clearly all of
these entities that I'm creating here by
just making new classes clearly what
they are are essentially a a composition
of various different either data or
behaviors right so for example an audio
mesh I mean it says it in the title
right audio mesh it's it hasn't it's an
entity that has an audio clip and also
has a mesh so instead of having to
create a new class which is a subclass
of entity and and you know might have to
have certain behaviors associated with
it and we don't know what to do when we
update it and whatever why not why not
just have the audio part of this this
audio clip as an actual maybe class
which we'll call audio component now
what this is going to be is the data
that is our audio clip alright so we'll
have audio clip clip here right and then
the mesh part of it why not make a class
or we can really just make these strokes
I guess it doesn't really matter
obviously but struct mesh component why
not make that a mesh here so right right
so this mesh component has an actual
pointer to a real mesh asset or
something like that I mean in a more
complex situation it might have like an
asset handle and it might you know not
directly linked to an asset like this
but whatever same with audio clip so we
have this right now that we have this
why not then make it so that and you
know light obviously is the same thing
let's just quickly redo light as well so
we have light and it has all these
properties you know type type whatever
now that we have all these components
why not then just take entity and say
that instead of entity containing even
any data or item anything have this
stuff maybe but instead of instead of it
containing anything why doesn't it just
contain like a bunch of components okay
well how do we do that well again not
the best solution but you know let's
just say we have a base classical
component and the benefit here is that
we can obviously use we can obviously
use some sort of like you know
inheritance here where maybe like a
light is a type of component right and
if we have everything as a type of
component then we can have like a vector
of components so we have all about
components right and then they're all
instances of one of these types and this
is all great because it means that like
you know we can you know we this can be
completely modular if we just if we want
to create a new entity on the fly that
again is like that enemy that has a
match in an audio clip and then also has
a flashlight well we just push a light
component into here
sorry my friend well he we just push a
light component into this components
list right and this vector now has a
whole bunch of components and this might
seem like a great solution and I mean
arguably is probably better than the
inheritance situation we had before this
little bit of inheritance going on right
but it's it's still like it's not bad we
essentially end up with a bunch of
entities that we don't have a billion
classes we just have a class picking per
component or a struct per component and
then if we if it's time for us to
compose Aaron C we can compose it out of
any number of components and that's
fantastic because if you think about it
without even having to write card we've
suddenly we've suddenly made our
entities extremely dynamic because as I
mentioned if I have an enemy or
something that has a mesh in an audio
clip I can decide to give it a light I
can decide to give it a flashlight and
that's just it's as easy as just adding
that light component to that entity
suddenly it's it's a it's a lit entity
or whatever right we have this new found
ability to be able to come
those things and that is probably one of
the strongest part of this ECS you can
hear this tossed around a lot
composition over inheritance instead of
us inheriting certain things and then
adding more behaviors onto it and then
you know deciding that well okay if I
want something to be alight and an audio
saw I can't you know can't have multiple
inheritance potentially I mean equipment
and not really so instead of that I
guess I'll just add rain more code it
doesn't make sense but with this you
have that list of components and you can
push everything into it again in
practice and sorry in theory sounds
great in practice that's still not a
great solution and the reason that it's
not a great solution well there's a lot
of reasons it's not a great solution but
the reason we'll focus on today which is
the real reason asterisk is performance
if I have a whole bunch of entities in
the scene and I'm talking about like a
lot let's just say a million just
because I'll just throw that number out
there I have 1 million entities in the
same how would I deal with all of these
components so as I mentioned before if
it's time to render this we obviously
need to go through all of the entities
that have a mesh or all of all of the
entities that that um you know have a
light or or like have a light component
I guess right or all the entities that
you know maybe have an audio clip we
want to go through all of those entities
and we want to be able to play that
audio or like play the next few samples
of that audio whatever all right so if
we're the renderer I would want to get
through this or maybe we have a script
component so like you know we have a few
entities linked up to a C sharp script
the C sharp script has an update
function right so obviously we need to
go through all the entities and anything
that has a seashell script attached that
has a valid update function we need to
call into that function to make sure
that MC is updated if they have if their
particle systems or if their physics
based we need to make sure we update the
physics we kind of start to reach this
problem where if I just have inside
scene right if in inside scene if I
have this like array of entities and
inside entity right I have an array of
components then what I kind of have to
do and you know I mean the way I've
written this is crudely doesn't have to
be dis bad all right like I have a
vector of components you would never
have a vector of components at the very
least you'd have like an unordered set
or something like that because usually
in these entity component systems you
can't have more than one component all
right you all you can't be you can't
have more than one light or you can't
have more like you know this entity if
it is like ether has a light or it
doesn't have a lot if you want to have
multiple lights well usually you'd make
multiple entities if you and and you
know in this in the case of the
flashlight example I know I know I kind
of added that to the entity but usually
you'd have like you you know you'd have
a lot a lot entity that was kind of
attached to your main mesh entity like
by being a child of it so it's like
parent is that measure entity in that
way you know the transform kind of moves
with the entity in any way a few few
different things going on there but for
the most part you know you kind of have
one one component you need to have one
component the entity and like with
script components maybe the script
component itself can contain multiple
c-sharp scripts or something like that
that way you can get around that by
essentially having a list of scripts and
therefore you can attach multiple of
behaviors to one entity which might be
desirable anyway the point is though you
usually have like one of these so maybe
you have like a map or a set or
something that can you know deal with
that so it doesn't have to be that bad
but ultimately how do we get through
this let's picture a real world example
well we have to have an update function
for our scene so maybe on scene update
so we have seen on update so inside this
function right we kind of have to go
through every entity we have to go
through every entity so we have a for
loop iterating all over the entities
right so we go through every entity and
then inside there what if we need to
render everything so we need to submit
all of our matters for rendering well I
guess for every entity we need to ask it
does it have a mesh does this entity
have a mesh component if it does submit
it for rent a submit it for rendering
I'm not sure what's going on here submit
write surrender or submit mesh whatever
and we submit it if it's a light well
you know add it to the scene as a light
I guess if it's an audio clip do this it
it becomes a huge mass if it's a physics
thing then added you know simulate it do
something with it move it I don't know
if it's script then updated it it gets a
little bit messy but the problem here is
that if we have a million entities and
they're all like they're you know
they're sorting a vector in this at this
point in time so they're literally I
mean it might be a vector of pointers so
maybe have a pointer here and it links
somewhere else and then you ultimately
have like you know we had a vector of
components or a set of components which
are all pointers as well and it goes
somewhere else in memory and then this
is like our transform component which we
kind of need right or this is our mesh
component that we want to submit right
maybe this one is our pointer to our
mesh component that we want to submit
then when we look at this we suddenly
need to you can see the memory reader
the memory indirection happening here
right not to mention that we have to
loop through every entity which again is
a completely in a completely different
memory address and we don't even know if
it has the right components so we need
to have a branch there like an if
statement and then when we finally do
decide we want it we have to go
somewhere else in memory this is
terrible for something called the CPU
cache or cache or whatever you guys like
to have you like to say I said cache
because I'm from Australia so this CPU
cache is very very important and we're
not going to talk about it here but
essentially the problem with these
memory directions is that if if we're
not dealing with memory that is
contiguous meaning that like literally
we're not dealing with a whole bunch of
bytes at once the CPU may potentially
need to fetch some memory that is stored
in a different place in our CPU RAM
right the RAM associated with our CPU so
not GPU Ram and via Ram but CPU Ram so
if we're trying to do a cold memory rate
meaning we're reading from a location
that is not in any of our CPU caches
that can be around I don't know if this
is still accurate but like 200 CPU
cycles or probably about
hundred times more than just adding two
numbers together to give you some
perspective right
the point is it's slow if you happen to
have your memory all in one place then
it's a way way way faster because what
happens is when you ask the CPU to give
you you want to take some memory you
want to take some data from your RAM and
actually do something with it and load
it into your CPU registers it goes into
your cache and you are able to then
since it's there you can read and write
into that cache a lot faster than you
can if you decide that I actually I need
to fetch some other stuff from elsewhere
right and because it's a lot faster it's
a lot better to have all that memory
close together and I don't know if I
mentioned this or not but the point
being that when you ask your CPU for
some for some memory it doesn't just get
you you know that one INT which is four
bytes it will get you a whole bunch of
memory starting from the location that
you asked for going forwards and since
it does that you'll basically just
collaterally I guess get extra bytes of
memory that you didn't even ask for and
it's it's right there on your doorstep
and so instead of going all the way back
to the post office to collect your
parcel because it's at your doorstep you
just pick it up from your doorstep it's
a lot faster to access that I don't know
what that analogy came from anyway so
the point is we want to take advantage
of the fact that our CPU doesn't just
give us what we asked for it gives us a
little bit ahead as well so and we take
advantage of that by basically saying
that my data the data then want to use
the data that I'm now going to iterate
over especially when you're using for
loops this is important right the data
then want to iterate or vote using my
for loop I'm gonna pack the important
stuff close together I'm gonna be a
little bit more data-driven in - what
Dodger and all that stuff development
whatever comes from right I'm going to
care about how my daughter is laid out
because it's going to mean that my data
is sorry that um that's gonna mean that
I can kind of get through that that data
more effectively and process it a lot
faster then if I have to just if I'm all
over the place right it's a lot quicker
to staple a whole bunch of documents on
your desk that are right here then if
they will scout around the desk and you
have to reach from there you have to get
the other
you pay pages to dis staple it's
annoying if you have them all here it's
ready to go so the way that we do that
and this video is so long they've way
the way that we this were going to be
like a quick time I was worried that
this video will be too short for one
episode anyway um the way that we do
this is we say that okay I get that in
my head
entities might be like I might have a
list of entities but really what I want
is I clearly want to just have all my
components together I want to have all
of my transformed components all of my
mesh components in one spot because if I
have this contiguous array of mesh
components and this is all of my meshes
right these are all of my mesh
components then guess what I can iterate
through this array where everything is
close together and I can submit that to
the renderer right now I may need
multiple things I may need the mesh and
the transform but that's still fun I
might need
I might need I don't know I might need
to update all my scripts so I iterate
through all of my script script
components and they're kind of all
together in memory now you can you can
design an entity component systems which
staggered this a little bit we're not
going to get too much into this but
ultimately you can have something like
transform mesh transform mesh you can
get into some more complicated
complicated memory layouts but for the
most part if you have this list here
getting through this list is a lot
better than having to go through all of
your entities ask it if it even has the
component and then submit it because
think about it this way when you're
rendering your entity right if it has a
mesh component I mean you are going to
need the transform because I need to
know where on earth to render it maybe I
also need to know if that entity is
active and a few other housekeeping
things but ultimately if I'm going
through the meshes - if I'm going
through all my entities I see it has a
mesh I want to render it do I even need
to know that it's an entity or which end
see it is not for rendering meshes
although all the
render cares about as the yummy give me
a vertex buffer give me a material you
know give me an index buffer I'm good to
go
you know that's all it needs it doesn't
care what entity is coming from its
drawing pixels on the screen so so what
you do is you don't care about the
entity anymore you say that I just care
about all the meshes give me all of the
meshes that exist in this scene and I'm
gonna render that and that's kind of
where this comes in right if we have a
proper entity component system where we
have entities yes
their only reason we have entities is
because we need to be able to kind of
associate components with each other
right because I don't just need to be
like arcade the scene has a mesh
component in it I need to know what
transform belongs to that mesh so does
that that's that entity contain a
transform component and a mesh component
right if I have a script associated with
it or an audio clip associated with a
particular thing I basically need that
relation right I need to be able to say
that I have a transform and mesh an
audio clip and a what was the other
thing a c-sharp script I want to be able
to say that these four components are
kind of dead they should have some
relation and that's how we that's why we
use an entity in the first place just
because we need that relation we need to
be able to be aware of that relation
because if we're not aware of that
relation then we have no idea when the
co-op script asks for its transform how
does it know what the transform is when
the c-sharp script says hey play the
audio clip how does it know which audio
clip to play would they need to be
related and that's how they're related
by the entity but when it comes down to
it if we just need an identifier to be
able to relate things together then
that's what entity is entity is just an
ID and it can be like you know I mean we
can have like a hundred and twenty eight
bit like universally unique identifiers
which is usually what game engines would
have we can have like I mean and ant the
the framework or the interpreter system
uses a very simple kind of incrementing
ID because it's not meant to be
universally unique and on something to
game image and can handle anyway but the
point is it can just be a number like
five so this entity is the number five
which means that this c-sharp
pertinent is associated with entity five
this audio clip is associated with
entity five and that's how you can
actually communicate between components
and also ask hey does this entity have
this component right instead of kind of
going through the entity you kind of go
through just the container of components
and you ask it hey I want to know if
entity ID v if v has an audio clip so
you can still query it like that but the
benefit is that since that's kind of
that's less that's more of a rare
situation your most common situation is
this it's the hey I need to play all my
audio clips please give me all the audio
clips in my scene and because they're
all stored together right and there's 1
million entities you don't have to go
through the 1 million entities to get
all the audio clips because you just
have like a pool or a vector or a
contiguous array of audio clip after
audio clip you just go through that and
you do whatever job you need to do now
the system part of entity component
system is I don't know I always tell
people not to worry too much about this
because if you kind of get this right if
you get right what I just said with just
the fact that like entities are kind of
just like an identifier that is used to
group components together and you
actually have pools of components and
all that stuff the system's kind of come
in place a bit differently the point of
a system in the entity component system
is basically to have to have some kind
of system that deals with a particular
component so in other words I want to
have a system that deals with just my
transforms or I want to have a system
that just like this what I just showed
you this kind of renderer mesh system
that's a system right it goes through
all of my meshes in my scene and it said
mr. it submits them to the renderer and
it renders them right a system might be
a physics system that it you know it
might have multiple components inside it
right like is in it rather you might
require multiple components so might
need the kind of rigidbody component but
also the transform because it needs to
update to transform with whatever the
physics simulation says is the new
position right it might need to do a
number of things there but ultimately
that's what a system is it's just
something that goes for components it
doesn't really care about entities it
can't care about relations but it's not
supposed to like all it really sees is
the component
and it does something to them so it
might update the c-sharp scripts right
now do I think that you should write
separate classes that are just systems
and like that's a that's a long story
and something else and ultimately nor I
think there's a system part of an entity
component system just it just comes
naturally really and I don't see a much
benefit of really kind of segregating it
too much from your core scene
the point is that you have that list of
components and you can deal with that I
think that's pretty much it hopefully
that makes sense you guys have any more
questions I was tempted to livestream
this just so I could answer questions
and stuff but if you have any more
questions or Corrections maybe I said
something wrong let me know in the
comments below I think that pretty much
covers antique entity component systems
so much of this kind of functionality in
this storage of pools and this kind of
classification of entities and their
relations and padding components
removing components having registries of
components that belong to a specific
scene all of that is going to be handled
by and right so all we need to do is
basically either create some kind of
good API that will easily allow us to
access all of these components and
entities in the way that we see fit and
then that's kind of like yes and we'll
kind of make sure that everything else
works for us and that iterating over
either selective components or groups of
components or otherwise we might want
the transform and the mesh at the same
time all of that kind of storage in like
the way that those arrays are stored and
and iterated over that will all be
handled by ant so all the hard work is
kind of done for us all we really need
to do is just use it and make sure that
we kind of you know make sure that we
provide components that just contain
data only no behavior and then we can
deal we can actually deal with the
behavior as part of the system which
iterates through all of the like
components of a particular type or types
and actually works with them anyway
hope you guys enjoy this video if you
did please don't forget to hit the like
button again questions comments concerns
Corrections leave them all in the
comment section below don't forget to
help support this series and everything
i'm doing
you began patient accomplish the show no
huge thank you to everyone who helps
support this keep in mind that I already
have ant or entity up and running in the
hazel development branch which you'll
get access to by helping to support the
series on patreon my channel on patreon
all that stuff and I already have like a
same system with entities and you can
even use the UI to create them in add
components to them and do all that stuff
so if you're interested in jumping ahead
you don't want to wait for us to do this
stuff within this series which we will
do in the coming episodes yeah you can
just jump jump on that you know you'll
help support this series and you'll get
access to all that code basically early
and I mean that's got like full-on
c-sharp scripting and you can basically
make a game and one thing what because
this in that development branch so if
you're interested definitely check it
out anyway thank you guys so much for
watching and I will see you next time
goodbye
[Music]